the claim on the left is that the the
gen the so-called gender binary is
western colonialism and that if you go
outside the western colonial bubble
you'll find that they're all very
progressive in their gender ideas
right and so that's why that is why we
went to africa
because i kept hearing i couldn't figure
out in the trailer why he's in some
african truck like what is the point of
this
we went to app let me just clarify we
went to africa number one to troll the
libs like that's the number one reason
we were there um that's true missionary
work by the way let me just be
so and we we had security meetings
before this africa trip and they said
you know
like you're going into kenya it's pretty
safe but they've got terrorists there
you could get kidnapped and
it's like i'm it's it's worth it to own
the libs i will i will give my life for
this cause i will
um
anyway
the real reason we went there was to
test this hypothesis on the left
about whether or not it's true that the
gender binary is is a western contract
and what we found is that well actually
when you get outside of the western
bubble
all there is is the so-called binary and
they have never even heard of any of
this stuff we're talking about in the
west and then it and then it flipped
into this really interesting thing
because i'm talking we went down we
talked to the messiah tribe in kenya and
they live in in huts that are made of
cow dung and they're they're
semi-nomadic they don't have electricity
or anything it's it's you know they're
living in the wilderness
and uh we're talking to them and and i'm
asking them these questions about
well can a man become a woman uh you
know can women does is it possible for a
woman to have a penis can men give birth
to babies and they're looking at me in
just utter horror and confusion
and
they also
assume that i believe this stuff myself
i never explained to them i didn't
right that's the funniest point the part
is that matt's just staring at them and
they're they're starting to they're
starting to circle you yeah like they're
calling in reinforcements and then they
and then they start weapons start
emerging exactly well they all had their
uh you know they had certain like clubs
that they walked around with spears
but
then i was i was in this interesting
position where they were wanting me and
they were all very patient like they
were treating me like i'm a confused
child and they said let we'll spread
explains to you but then they wanted me
to explain these ideas to them and then
it's actually very revealing
when you try to explain an idea to
someone who's never heard of it before
that's when you can really see if this
idea makes any sense at all because this
is someone who does not have any of the
shared kind of frameworks that we do
none of the shared biases none of that
and so you're starting at ground zero
can i explain
gender fluidity to this tribal
community from ground zero and the
answer is no it's just total nonsense
they don't even have the words like i'm
talking to uh
you know the elder in the tribe through
a translator
and he doesn't have the word i tried to
get him to ask the tribal elder about
non-binary people
and he says he says what he doesn't have
the words for that so
they literally don't have the words to
even talk about these things it's that
far outside of their experience
we'll keep chatting i think we have a
clip that i want to show from that if
our team could get it just a short clip
so if you guys could pull that up and
tell me when it's ready but matt that's
so interesting because that is you know
a common critique i go to berkeley and
boulder and you speak at all the same
campuses as well and they'll always say
no the problem is the western colonial
framework that if you break people back
in the state of nature
and especially in tribes is actually one
they use
especially kind of the breakup of kind
of colonial
or i guess colonial breakup of
indigenous people in africa then there
really is no such thing as these gender
norms and they repeat it with such kind
of
intensity that you almost it almost
takes you back and and they also
they can make these claims because they
don't think anyone will be crazy enough
to actually go ask any of these people
these questions and even though i did
this the the rejoinder now from the left
has been
well you only talked to one primitive
african tribe
and i'm like dude you can go talk to
some more yourself like go ahead bring a
camera crew find a different tribe in
africa and ask them all about gender
fluidity and go ahead go ahead prove me
wrong
because this is this is all an insular
like you said luxury
uniquely western belief and also very
modern that is not shared by anyone and
that includes by the way
some of these uh some of these cultures
where they where they'll claim here's
another one
they'll say well native americans have
two spirit and they actually have added
two spirit to the lgbt
acronym now on the ever expanding
acronym they now have they have numbers
in it now for two s for two spirit right
so
that's what they say they say well
native americans they have two spirits
that's just like trans
all you do is take ten seconds to google
this stuff and you discover that two
spirit that term was coined guess what
guess when
1990 is when they came up with that it
was lgbt activist and not they make it
sound like this is something that the
the cheyenne were talking about or the
zoo or the iroquois right right
yeah the apache on the great plains in
1801 were like running around talking
about their fluid genders no this is
lgbt activists made this up
recently and now are claiming that this
is some cultural belief